meine freiheit ist nicht durch eine
tätigkeit oder
gefühl näher definiert
es ist er eigentlich eher so ein
grundlegendes bedürfnis und empfinden
ich kann da sehr intuitiv meine
persönliche freiheit beginnt und endet
dort wo ich machen will was ich nicht
lassen kann ich würde sagen freiheit
merke ich tatsächlich am stärksten an
meiner aktuellen situation dass ich
machen kann was ich will dass ich
philosophie studieren kann und nicht
gezwungen werden irgendwelche dinge
machen zu müssen
ich glaube das ist eine freiheit die wir
in deutschland genießen sicherheit ist
das was uns dazu fähig alles andere zu
schaffen was für den kopf gesetzt haben
und da bin ich sehr glücklich in dieser
in der westlichen welt sehr behütet
aufgewachsen zu sein und quasi nicht den
den erwerbs druck zu haben dem jetzt
andere in anderen ländern indien
kinderarbeit zwangsheiraten und
natürlich die zusagen in erwerbsarbeit
als als bauer in afrika der für seinen
lebensunterhalt arbeiten muss und nicht
zur schule gehen kann weil er sonst
nicht zu essen hat dieses gefühl sicher
zu sein
es ist ein klassisches weißes blatt
papier für alles andere also ich lebe
meine freiheit gerne durch tanzen tanzen
aus komplett freies tanzen
das wäre auf körperlicher ebene sich
nicht verstellen zu müssen sondern
einfach mein selber zu sein auch mal
seine intuition seinen effekten einfach
freien lauf zu lassen und sich nicht
unbedingt gedanken darüber zu machen was
andere denken einfach seinen interessen
auch nachgehen zu können
überhaupt legt man selbst zu sich selbst
zu sein und sich nicht von außen zu sehr
lenken zu lassen
dieser sorgt immer wieder für sich
selbst zu hinterfragen ob man dem
glauben schenken möchte oder nicht
innerlich keine barrieren zu haben
sondern sondern ganz frei und ohne
vorurteile auch über sich selbst
nachdenken zu können
aber ich finds genauso wichtig genau das
gegenteil machen zu können und sich weil
vollständig ablenken zu können von dem
von ihm denken und von dem von diesen
dogmatisch und manchmal auf und setze
ich mich mehr und nicht weniger als ganz
grundlegende persönlichen zeigen nicht
nur aus dem verstand herauszutreten
sondern auch mal auf sein brauche ich um
zu gehen so wie ich dann eigentlich im
letzten ende auch philosophie kommen hat
sich von gut herausgestellt begeistert
darüber ich glaube und so glücklich
haben ist umso mehr man den weg zum
blick hin geht um die freiheit dann auch
man muss sich selbst lieben lernen und
erst dann kann man wirklich frei sein
ansonsten trägt man noch immer so eine
fassade mit sich herum und fassade ist
schwer häuser haben schwere fassaden
das ding ist grant mich dadurch ja auch
wieder ein wenn ich wirklich frei sein
will und mir vorgaben macht wie ich frei
zu sein habe wenn ich wieder nicht bei
[Applaus]